ein nachbarschaftsstreit in thüringen
familie entsteht aus sangerhausen war
nur für einen tag mal eben kurz in
berlin
und als sie zurückkamen war ein fenster
ihres büros zugebaut nämlich mit dem
wintergarten des nachbarn eine irre
geschichte ja wohl einen tag dem ja auch
nicht da und da musste das zu ihr macht
mit dieser überraschung hatte familie
schlennstedt aus sangerhausen in
thüringen wohl nicht gerechnet haus
formales und jemand peter waren nur für
einen tag nach berlin gefahren als das
bad zurückkam trauten sie ihren augen
nicht das fenster vom arbeitszimmer ist
komplett zugebaut mit der
brandschutzmauer von nachbars neu im
wintergarten seit vier jahren läuft hier
schon einen nachbarschaftsstreit dieses
gesagt das war schon immer drin
wir haben sogar 89 raub und das haus
haben wir von meiner oma übernommen
und die hatten das in den 50er jahren
gekauft
nachbarn hatten wir beim bauamt ein
antrag gestellt und die haben das
genehmigt
da wusste man aber zu diesem zeitpunkt
noch nicht was das bedeutet dass die
fenster zumachen komme aus nordafrika
sind an dem besagten darf was wenn es
dazu
um von dem abdach 1 haben wir sofort
klargestellt gegen das
verwaltungsgericht halle hat jetzt uns
beschieden dass es bleiben kann und das
kann nicht sein
das urteil würde ja auch bedeuten dass
jetzt jeder nachdem das nicht gefällt
wenn die fenster das zu seinem
grundstück rüber 8 dass der jetzt bauen
kann
nachbarin kerstin gehe antwortet auf
bild-nachfrage wir werden nie dicke
freunde
aber ärgern wollen wir sie auch nicht
das ohr verwaltungsgericht halle hatte
die klage von familie schlennstedt
abgewiesen die begründung weil das haus
der familie direkt an der
grundstücksgrenze steht hat der nachbar
das gleiche recht
das ehepaar ist empört sie wollen nun
vor das oberverwaltungsgericht ziehen ja
wirklich ein irrer fall
und ganz wichtig sangerhausen liegt in
sachsen anhalt und nicht in thüringen
jahn kempten schüttelt auch mit dem kopf
was ist da schiefgelaufen
also man hört ja so in der anwaltlichen
praxis haben wir jeden tag die
verrücktesten geschichten und das ist so
eine geschichte wo man auf den ersten
moment im ersten augenblick ein bisschen
schmunzelt da wird einfach ein fenster
zugemauert da werden tatsachen
geschaffen und dann muss man sich hier
mit zum klageverfahren wären tatsächlich
ist das für die betroffenen natürlich
eine ganz schlimme situation denn der
wohnwert der immobilie auch der
tatsächliche wert der immobilie wird er
erheblich beeinträchtigt also von daher
vollkommen verständlich dass man sich
dagegen wehrt und hier muss man sagen
dieses nachbarrecht ist länder recht es
gibt also landes satzungen die das
nachbarrecht regeln da geht es um
abstandsflächen es geht auch um den ja
um die berühmte hecke die immer wieder
zum streit führt wie hoch darf sie sein
wie dicht sein
und dann gibt es noch ort satzungen und
es gibt noch ortsüblichkeit aber ich
muss da wirklich zur warnung sagen so
nachbarschaft streitereien vermehren
sich wie die weißen mäuse wenn man
einmal anfängt dann geht's wirklich
weiter und am ende gewinnen fast in
solchen fällen immer nur die anwälte
deshalb sollte man wirklich von
vornherein hier vorsichtig sein und vor
allen dingen miteinander auch ins
gespräch kommen
genau das ist auch unser thema
tatsächlich wenn der stein erst mal in
den brunnen gefallen ist dann kriegt man
da halt nicht wieder raus und dann
meckert der eine über die hecke der
anderer über die das licht die musik und
da kommt dann ziemlich viel zusammen ja
das muss ja auch nicht unbedingt sein an
can dance hat es auch richtig an
moderiert am ende freuen sich die
anwälte und ich bin jetzt zugeschaltet
mit christian wermke er ist auch
rechtsanwalt aber ein experte beim thema
verhandlungsgeschick also ich merke dass
auch überall bei unseren geschichten die
wir so von unseren reportern bekommen da
schießt der eine gegen in anderen land
kommt der andere mit einer retourkutsche
und das schaukelt sich halt so hoch muss
das überhaupt immer so sein
nein das problem beim vorliegenden fall
ist dass der streit wie ich jetzt aus
hab schon seit vier jahren am schwelen
ist und einer meine mentorin andreas
winheller hat mal gesagt es gibt keine
kreativität im schützengraben also wenn
wir jetzt schon im schützengraben sind
und das ist nach vier jahren durchaus
der fall dann kommen wir auch mit
kreativität oft nicht mehr weiter und
das ist dann letztlich der letzte weg
vor gericht zu ziehen
wenn wir allerdings nicht so weit sind
da gibt es durchaus einige möglichkeiten
die ich gerne zur verfügung stelle
wie man es von anfang an so etwas
vermeiden kann ja das ist ganz wichtig
tatsächlich es geht ja auch klein los es
muss ja nicht immer gleich der
wintergarten sein der da aufgebaut wird
aber tatsächlich ärgerlich mensch der es
immer so laute musik nebenan und javi
wie gehe ich davor wie setzt sich dann
schon irgendwie mein recht auf ruhe
durch ohne jetzt aber wirklich den
nachbarn vom kopf zu stoßen
also es gibt schon mal drei dinge die
sehr wichtig sind nämlich einmal
ignorieren sie den konflikt nicht das
ist ein sehr sehr wichtiger punkt nicht
ignorieren so und vor allem auch nicht
verharmlosen na ja es wird nur das eine
mal gewesen sein oder heute war es ja
nicht ganz so laut und gleichzeitig
machen sie das zwischen sich und dem
nachbarn aus und lassen sie sich nicht
aufheizen indem sie möglichst mit
dritten darüber sprechen die dann so
sätze sagen wie das kannst du dir nicht
gefallen lassen oder ich hab da mal
einen forum gelesen dass es so einer der
schlimmsten sätze für rechtsanwälte wenn
jemand sagt ich habe meinen forum was
gelesen weil das nachbarschaftsrecht ist
durchaus auch individuell recht und das
hat etwas mit haltung zu tun
das hat auch was damit zu tun dass es
keine objektive wahrnehmung gibt sondern
eben nur subjektive wahrnehmung will
heißen da hat letztlich jeder irgendwie
recht und da gibt es eine methode die
ich gerne anbieten kann
die nennt sich www methode der hat aber
nichts mit internet zu tun sondern damit
dass sie direkt und unverzüglich den
nachbarn ansprechen und ihre wahrnehmung
zunächst äußern das erste w in einer ich
botschaft ich nehme wahr dass die musik
heute extrem laut war zwischen 22 uhr
und 23 uhr es kommt das zweite baby
wirkung und das hat mich wirklich sehr
gestört und ich habe nicht mein schlaf
gestört gefühlt weil die schicht
arbeitet zum beispiel und dann kommt der
wunsch und ich würde mir wünschen wenn
sie das abspielen lauter musik
beschränken würden bis zu den
offiziellen zeiten 22 uhr beim dieser
zeit nehme ich auch gerne hin
und in diesem in dieser situation wenn
so formuliert wird keiner kann mir meine
wahrnehmung vorwerfen und wenn ich es
frühzeitig tue dann komme ich auch mit
dem nachbarn ins gespräch und konkret in
die lösungsorientierung vielleicht mit
einem letzten satz hinten dran wie
würden sie das sehen um einen
perspektivwechsel anzustoßen
ja das klingt wirklich sehr sehr
vernünftig und kempkens muss ich denn
damit rechnen also ich es kann ja nicht
so sein dass ich jetzt nie mehr ein
tagesausflug machen kann um zu
verhindern dass mein nachbar dann da
irgendwelche bauten hochzieht muss sich
dann auch als eigentümer schauen ja
welches recht hatten der der nachbar
auch und könnte er das dann durchsetzen
also tatsächlich auch damit rechnen dass
man da vielleicht auch mal den
wintergarten hingesetzt bekommt wie
sehen sie das
also ich finde das schon ziemlich
unverfroren muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen
hier sein wenn das tatsächlich so einen
urlaubstag genutzt wurde um hier fakten
zu schaffen findet schon ziemlich
unverfroren muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen
ist auch nicht fair dem nachbarn
gegenüber
und da fällt mir so aus meiner eigenen
anwaltlichen praxis immer so der der der
fall der eigentlich sich immer wieder
holt ein unter diesen
nachbarschaftsstreit rain man spricht
also mit den mandanten der mandant
schildert die situation sowie aus seiner
sicht so sich so darstellt und dann hat
man so den eindruck was muss das für ein
monster sein auf der anderen grundstück
seite weil man ja als anwalt immer so
die situation auch ein nennt man kann
das sehr gut nachvollziehen was erzählt
wird man denkt sich genau da rein und
denkt so ja das ist ja völlig das ist ja
ein monster der da nebenan wohnt und
dann kommt es zu gerichtsterminen oder
zu gütetermin bei schied ämtern oder
dergleichen und dann lernt man auf
einmal als anwalt auch den nachbarn
kennen so zu sagen weil er ja auf der
gegenseite ist und er hat eigentlich
auch ein ganz vernünftiges vorlegen und
da denkt man sich noch so ein monster
ist das ja gar nicht offenbar der ist ja
gesprächsbereit denn oftmals sind das
leute wenn man so einzeln mit entspricht
es sind die oft sehr eloquent die sind
sehr freundlich haben eigentlich ganz
klare vorstellungen auch und man hat so
den eindruck an
an einer stelle ist der schalter falsch
gelegt worden und das ist dann der punkt
wo es dann eben teurer wird und das ist
dann der punkt wo dann auch solche
sachen passieren was hier erlebt haben
und deshalb muss ich immer sagen man
sollte wie der kollege auch gerade schon
zurecht sagt immer so ein bisschen
versuchen sich in die andere situation
hinein zu verdenken
und dann irgendwie noch zugucken
irgendwo noch einen vergleich zu
erzielen denn bei gericht müssen immer
alle federn lassen das kann ich ihnen
aus jahrelanger erfahrung sagen da
spricht jemand der sich auskennt aber
christian wermke kennt sich auch aus da
mal eine frage an sie sollte ich denn
vielleicht auch mit meinem nachbarn
grundsätzlich reden vielleicht beim bier
beim grillen
du weißt du wenn mich irgendetwas stört
dann sagst mir bitte und dann versuchen
wir das hinzukriegen um auch tatsächlich
diese kommunikationsebene hinzukriegen
absolut es ist letztlich immer zu
empfehlen in einer ehe und nichts
anderes ist es letztendlich wenn man
direkt nebeneinander und miteinander zu
kommunizieren
man muss nicht beste freunde sein aber
ich denke es ist sehr sehr wichtig die
amerikaner nennen das perspektiv taking
gebildet also die perspektive des
anderen einzunehmen und die welt aus
seiner sicht zu sehen
und also wenn das nicht bei einem bier
und bei den kirchen geht dann weiß ich
auch nicht
absolut auch ganz ganz wichtige hinweise
vielen dank christian wermke vielen dank
an kempkens